what's the largest animal you can think
of okay that's probably too vague of a
question your mind probably went
straight to the oceans picturing deep
sea leviathans like the mighty blue
whale let's go a little bit closer shall
we what about on land what are the
biggest animals that live up here with
us above the water elephants maybe what
about rhinos then again hippos are up
there too in the same kind of ballpark
all pretty huge what about cows they can
grow pretty big right especially with
all the crazy growth hormones that meat
manufacturers pump into them these days
well what if there was something out
there bigger than all of those imagine
it some huge beast roaming the
wilderness that easily towered above any
creature you've ever seen in your life
this thing would be massive striding
across the world towering above the
meager height of a human being now
imagine that this
thing whatever it was wasn't just big
but kept getting
bigger sure all of this might sound like
the premise for the next godzilla or
cloverfield movie but while big charlie
might not be the king of the monsters it
certainly lives up to that first part of
its nickname of course the scp
foundation calls it scp-4158
big charlie is just the playful nickname
that the owners gave it although none of
them are sure who was the first to call
the creature by that name standing on
four long legs at 3.4 meters tall when
the foundation first discovered it
scp-4158 was about one and three-fifths
times as tall as famous professional
basketball player shaquille o'neal but
since then well like we said big charlie
is getting bigger day by day the
creature appears to be tangentially
related to the bovine family of mammals
essentially making it a ginormous cow
however scp-4150
lacks the facial structure and features
that you might expect to see on the
faces at your local farm the creature
has thin translucent skin which is so
fragile that it often tears easily and
anyone observing
scp-4158 can often see the bones and
internal organs within
gross it possesses a large bulbous head
with a protrusion at the front almost
like a beak as well as that its huge
eyes are foggy a milky white color which
seems to suggest that scp-4158
is at least partially blind the large
cadillac mammal is incredibly skinny
almost to the point where its bones
stick out from underneath its skin its
legs are longer than the rest of its
colossal body and seem barely able to
support the animal's weight on
description alone you can't help but
feel sorry for the poor creature and its
sorry state of living normally big
charlie is mostly calm and docile barely
acknowledging the foundation personnel
that come to examine it feed it or clean
its containment cell held in a heavy
containment zone
scp-4158 is fed through a 5-meter trough
on the far east wall of its cell
surviving on a diet of raw beef hay wood
and bricks not the typical grass-only
eating habits you'd expect from normal
cows but according to the foundation's
extensive testing on the creature its
diet doesn't seem to be what is causing
scp-4158 to keep growing at the rate it
has been the mass of big charlie is in
some sort of state of perpetual increase
meaning its size and weight are always
growing and it is because of this
continuous growth that every week the
foundation is forced to shear off great
swaths of excess meat from the creature
cleaving off its flesh and incinerating
the mass all while big charlie is still
alive now before you start dialing
peta's hotline it's also worth
mentioning big charlie can't feel pain
what's more testing has revealed that
the meat taken from scp-4158 is usda
utility grade beef the kind that would
normally come from older cattle utility
grade meat has no fat marbling so it
isn't as tender or as flavorsome as
other more premium grades but would
normally be used in canned and processed
food products and despite the foundation
destroying the excess that they cut off
of big charlie as a precaution in theory
the meat is still good to eat and
possesses no anomalous properties then
again would you really want to eat a
burger made from scp-4158
i didn't think so if left unchecked and
allowed to grow for longer than a week
scp-4158 will begin to form new features
limbs organs and sometimes even genitals
will sprout from random places all over
its body the previous record for big
charlie's most substantial growth was
when he increased to eight and a half
meters tall that's over three-fifths the
height of the hollywood sign and over
one and a half times the average height
of a giraffe at this immense size
charlie has developed seven legs four
stomachs three tons and numerous other
extremities before the scp foundation
cut him back down to size and we mean
they literally cut him back down so what
exactly is this thing it's like a giant
cow but not actually a cow even though
its flesh is identical to beef and it's
not a destructive rampaging monster
either showing no hostility towards
humans even when they are shearing its
excessive body mass away could it be
some kind of failed genetic experiment
an attempt to solve hunger by
engineering a creature that could not
only stay alive but keep growing after
having its meat cut away if that were
true it would make
scp-4158 a literal cash cow for the meat
industry
well we've got kind of a funny story
about that actually big charlie was
first encountered by the foundation back
in december 2004 in crude sin indiana a
number of calls have been made to the
area's local animal control services
with reports of a large cow with mange
roaming the nearby highway 17. two
officers belonging to the animal control
department were sent out to investigate
these reports and what they found was
scp-4158 wandering aimlessly but unlike
any cow they had ever seen the officers
called local police where a foundation
plant caught wind of what they had found
and called in containment specialists
the case was closed after the animal
control officers were given amnestics
and a cover story was put in place about
a cow with mange that was put down where
it had been found in reality the scp
foundation rounded up old big charlie
and transported it to safety with little
resistance from the animal they were
able to trace the creature's origin back
to somewhere called butcher's block a
nearby slaughterhouse the manager of the
establishment one jeff fein and a single
employee named barney mossman were
brought in by the foundation for
questioning another employee rory
gildson was also retrieved from his home
after having called in sick to work that
day barney mossman the first of the
butcher's block employees to be
interviewed stated that
scp-4158 had been called big charlie
since long before he had started his job
at the slaughterhouse according to his
testimony he knew nothing about where
the creature had actually come from only
that it was fed hay but would also
occasionally eat anything else it could
including other cows since joining
butcher's block four years earlier
mossman had been told not to ask
questions or to tell anyone else about
scp-4158
the morning after the huge creature had
seemingly escaped mr fine had apparently
angrily accused both barney and rory of
selling him out and giving big charlie
away to the competitors of butcher's
block even though they were the only
slaughterhouse in the area but mossman
was convinced that neither of them were
capable of doing something like that
rory apparently treated big charlie like
his own child and fein had an even
stranger relationship with the creature
rory gildson the other of fein's
employees was more helpful in shedding
light on
scp-4158's origin than barney had been
rory explained that he and jeff fein had
bought a pregnant cow from an unknown
person nine years earlier considering it
to be a steal a two for the price of one
bargain however one day without warning
the calf fell out of its mother it
wasn't born like any ordinary cow
however according to gildsyn it had
ripped through the mother cow's chest
and looked disgusting while rory and
jeff had initially thought the calf to
be dead they discovered it had tried to
get back into the barn after they hauled
it outside
their original intention had been to
sell the creature off for scientific
study or failing that to a freak show
however after their attempts to sell the
calf failed jeff and rory had decided
the best course of action would be to
put the animal down they had reason that
releasing it into the wild could have
negatively affected the ecosystem so
instead they took a bolt pistol and
pushed it between the creature's eyes
then fired but nothing happened rory
tried again but ended up breaking the
gun instead they slit the animal's
throat but it barely bled even
butchering it on the spot while it was
still alive did nothing finding gildson
reduced the calf to little more than a
skeleton but it simply refused to die
the pair of them packaged the meat they
had removed with the rest hoping no one
would notice or ask where it had come
from it was a few days later that rory
realized
scp-4158 was capable of regrowing
whatever was cut off of it he and his
boss even tried some and couldn't tell
the difference they had their hands on a
cow that would eat anything put in front
of it and that could produce infinite
meat the foundation probed rory guilds
in further for more information on the
creature learning that scp-4158 was
sterile and incapable of reproducing the
only one of its kind rory argued that
the foundation legally couldn't take big
charlie away that the creature was still
private property little did he realize
he was wrong but he just like barney
mossman also knew nothing about how the
animal had escaped in the first place
finally jeff fein the owner of the
butcher's block slaughterhouse was
questioned by the foundation he repeated
rory's earlier story about the strange
calf that had been born and how it could
regenerate the flesh that was sheared
off of it fein remarked that he
considered it to be a blessing when
asked about his whereabouts on the night
scp-4158 had escaped from butcher's
block jeff admitted that he had been
praying but not to god to big charlie he
had apparently been doing this every
night since realizing what the creature
could do viewing the animal as a
provider and a savior i just felt
something when i was around him i could
tell that he wanted to make this
sacrifice for us ever since he tried to
get into the barn after we threw him out
i knew he cared for us fine told the
foundation i would open his pen take off
my clothes so that i was pure before him
lay down and receive his blessings and
how would he receive those blessings by
drinking the animal's blood yeah jeff
fein was a real eccentric like that one
night when fein had entered the pen to
perform this weird ritual big charlie
had escaped but his owner was convinced
that there must have been a reason for
this that the animal had some sort of
goal when the foundation staff
conducting fein's interview dismissed
this idea the slaughterhouse owner
became enraged how dare you question big
charlie he knows what's best for all of
us i'm done here i don't need to keep
answering questions like this let me out
i need to see big charlie i need to see
if he's safe the foundation believes
that jeff fein's practice of worshiping
scp-4158 was not due to any anomalous
effect caused by the creature itself
none of the foundation personnel tasked
with feeding studying and shearing meat
off of big charlie have displayed any
similar behavior of performing abnormal
religious rituals he really was just a
huge weirdo as for the butcher's block
slaughterhouse fein and the rest of his
employees were given amnestics to forget
big charlie had ever even existed and
the slaughterhouse was closed under the
false pretense of a health code
violation and its staff being arrested
for malpractice the one question that
remains unanswered however is the
identity of the individual that first
sold jeff fine the cow that gave birth
to scp-4150
it just goes to show you though
sometimes you don't know where your food
is coming from if you lived in indiana
in late 2004 who knows you might have
eaten some of big charlie and not even
realized it now go check out scp-261
pan-dimensional vending machine and
scp-426 i'm a toaster for more scps that
might whet your appetite